We're crushing our coolest
videos into bite size pieces
for your inspiration
and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is
King of Random Rewind.
10. GUMMY ZOMBIE BRAINS
9. SODA SLUSHIES
8. TUXEDO ORIGAMI
7. BOILING COLA AND MILK
6. COCONUT GRENADES
5. GALLIUM PLAY BUTTON
4. LN2 COCONUT FREEZE
3. VACUUMING SOAP
2. CANDY HEART OF TE FITI
1. BANANA BLASTER
What's up guys?
It's Grant here.
If you liked this compilation
and want to see another one,
click the box up at the top.
If you want to see a
randomly selected video
for your viewing pleasure,
click the box on the bottom.
And if you want to
be a subscriber,
and you're not already in the club,
hit the bomb,
and we'll see you in the next video.